14 janvier 2021 4 heures du matin le
déclic
le jour qui a changé ma vie jusqu'à
présent le jour où j'ai décidé de
laisser mon passé derrière moi de
prendre mon futur en mains et de surtout
me concentrer sur le mois du présent le
jour où j'ai réalisé que pour connaître
du succès plus tard et dans le futur je
devais m'imposer une routine désagréable
au début oui mais plus que bénéfique au
long terme et qui ne m'apporterait que
du bien
cette routine que je me suis créé au fil
du temps m'a apporté une expérience de
vie que j'aimerais partager avec vous
douche froide méditation et prières
études travail sport rangement de
chambre et me voilà prêt à commencer ma
journée à 6h30 j'aimerais commencer ma
présentation en évoquant ses partir aux
grosses visqueuse et plus de cachet de
votre corps que l'on utilise tous les
jours
je parle bien évidemment de notre
cerveau qui jusqu'à présent fait l'objet
dans la liste pour comprendre de plus en
plus au fonctionnement et comment il
marche mais une chose est sûre c'est
qu'il ne s'est pas discerner le vrai du
faux et j'aimerais s'il vous plaît que
vous garder cela en tête pour plus tard
j'y reviendrai bonjour à tous je
m'appelle luxe à bord 17 ans et je suis
là pour vous faire part d'un sujet assez
connu mais peu appliqué chez les jeunes
gens de notre âge et de notre génération
il s'agit de la discipline
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce que la discipline eh bien
je ne vais pas vous donner une
définition simple est inutile que vous
trouverez sur le web mais plutôt ma
propre conception de celle ci la
discipline c'est le fait de faire une
certaine chose au moment le moins envie
de la faire c'est le fait de faire une
certaine chose malgré notre fatigue ou
notre paresse mais c'est surtout le fait
de faire quelque chose en sortant dans
notre zone de confort cette discipline
ne s'acquiert pas directement c'est un
long processus de plusieurs étapes à
franchir qui nous mène vers le succès
garanti quel que soit votre profession
plus tard
et bien la discipline je vous ai dit que
l ne s'acquiert pas directement et la
zone de confort en sortant d'elle-même
c'est quelque chose de très important
puisque cette zone et destructrice cette
zone est l'ennemi même de la
productivité est l'ennemi même de la
discipline est l'ennemi même du succès
j'aimerais s'il vous plaît que vous tous
ici vous nommiez une personne une seule
qui a réussi dans la vie sous l'effet
des tris sous l'effet des dans sa zone
de confort est ce l'effet de la facilité
nommez moi une personne
la réponse est pourtant claire mason
belle somme lui réussi dans la vie sous
l'effet de la facilité et personne dans
la vigne réussi dans la vie sous l'effet
d'être confortable 6 en surmontant les
épreuves en étant discipliné et par la
suite en surtemps dans leur zone de
confort que la réussite va s'offrir à
nous
mais comment et disciplinés comment
acquérir cette discipline et bien c'est
très simple je vous ai dit que le
cerveau ne s'est pas discerner le vrai
du faux eh bien à mesure que vous êtes
entrain d'habitués votre cerveau chaque
jour à réaliser des tâches de deux
minutes par jour qui ne prennent pas
plus de deux minutes et que normalement
vous n'aimez pas faire et vous ne voulez
pas faire vous allez voir comment vous
allez habituez votre cerveau à et dans
une optique productive et au long terme
est discipliné et par effet de
réciprocité vous rendre disciplinaire ce
cerveau à ce qu'on appelle une
plasticité
cette plasticité cérébrale et de manière
simplifiée une boîte mémoire qui stocke
ce que vous le nourrissez dutil au long
terme est bien à mesure que vous
nourrissez votre cerveau avec ce que
vous jugez dutil et de productif vous
allez voir comment volontaire vous allez
vous transformer en une personne
discipline est
une autre issue pour le développement de
la discipline chéri de se réveiller tôt
au lieu autre que de réaliser les tâches
2000 par jour qui ne prennent pas plus
de deux minutes vous devez vous
réveiller tôt mais pourquoi c'est prouvé
scientifiquement que se réveiller tôt
diminue grandement la procrastination
et qui dit procrastination di rupo
cement de tâches et qui dit repoussoir
de tâches 10 obstacles même à la
discipline et obstacles même au succès
est bien à mesure que vous vous
réveillez tout vous serez plus apte à
réaliser plus de tâches qui ne prennent
pas plus de deux minutes et que
normalement vous ne voulez pas faire et
vous allez voir comment vous allez
productif volontaire mais comment s'est
réveillée tôt c'est assez dur si on se
réveille normalement à 11h à 12h c'est
juste je deviens tôt mais il faut
appliquer cinq méthodes super simple et
vous allez voir comment avec le temps
vous allez pouvoir vous réveiller tôt
sans alarme ne m'aiment pas appliquer
ces cinq techniques qui sont sains et y
est hein pourquoi
sachez pourquoi vous avez envie de vous
réveiller tôt le matin dicter à votre
cerveau ce que vous avez envie de faire
le matin pour qu'il puisse vous
réveiller par automate yaisien le matin
tôt
2faites le fait de vous réveiller le
matin un accomplissement ou une
récompense comme ça vous allez habitués
le système de récompenses qui se trouve
dans votre cerveau à être heureux et
fiers de se réveiller tôt et donc au
long terme il va vouloir vous réveiller
tôt chaque jour 3 fait un plan de votre
matinée la nuit d'avant écrivait
extérioriser ce que vous avez envie de
faire le matin les tâches que vous avez
envie d'accomplir avec comme but votre
projet de vie et vous allez voir comment
en extériorisant les idées vous à les
formater votre cerveau à vous réveiller
tôt le matin pour que vous puissiez
accompli pour que vous puissiez
accomplir certaines tâches
4 mais des larmes loin de votre lit
comme ça vous allez vous lever les
teintes et vous serez déjà debout prêt à
entamer votre journée
eh bien oui c'est vrai que j'ai réveillé
tôt réaliser les tâches de minutes par
jour comme par exemple faire votre lit
le matin personne n'a envie de faire son
lit le matin mais lorsque vous vous
lever et dès le début de votre journée
dès le commencement de votre journée
vous êtes en train de réaliser une tâche
désagréable que vous n'aimez pas faire
normalement au long terme et au cours de
la journée vous serez beaucoup plus apte
à réaliser plus de tâches et bien fait
votre lit le matin je vous assure que ça
marche vous serez dans une optique plus
productifs au cours de votre journée et
au long terme on l'espère dans votre
projet de vie
et bien je vous ai dit que oui réalisez
les tâches de 2000 un jour sortir de
notre zone de confort se réveiller tôt
mais n'avaient mène vers la discipline
c'est vrai mais l'élément moteur c'est
votre cerveau
je vous ai dit que ce cerveau ne s'est
pas discerner le vrai du faux mais je
vous ai pas dit pourquoi eh bien je vais
vous faire part d'une expérience d'une
histoire plutôt qui a c'est vrai et qui
explique très bien au point de vue vous
avez déjà entendu parler de l'histoire
du chien de pavlov
ok pour ceux qui n'auront pour ceux qui
n'ont pas entendu parler de cette
histoire c'est en fait l'histoire d'un
chien et de son maître qui chaque soin
au moment du dîner le mettre sous cloche
le chien arrive en bavent en salivant
devant sa nourriture dans sa gamelle est
bien un jour passe deux jours passent
plusieurs jours passent et chaque soir
le maître sonne la cloche le chien
arrive en bavant devant sa gamelle est
bien un jour le maître est venu il a
sonné la cloche le chien est arrivé il a
vu qu'il n'y a pas de nourriture devant
dans sa gamelle mais il a quand même
avait il ya qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est en fait que le m il allie un il a
lié un stimulus neutre qui est le
retentissement de la cloche un stimulus
inconditionnels qui le fait de baver
devant sa nourriture et bienveillance et
de stimulus le chien ne sait plus
discerner le vrai du faux en voyant sa
nourriture dans la gamelle il n'y a pas
de garde il n'y a pas de nourriture dans
la gamelle mais il va quand même eh bien
c'est la même chose avec nous les
humains si chaque jour vous viendrez
d'habitués votre cerveau à réaliser les
tâches de 2000 par jour ou bien à sortir
de ma zone de confort ou bien s'est
réveillée tôt mais les pages qui sont
productives et d'âge discipline et vous
allez voir comment avec le temps il va
s'habituer par eiffel ipso facto d'être
dans une petit productive volontaire et
au cours de votre vie pour votre projet
de vie et votre but de vie
et bien je vous ai dit qu'il fallait
sortir de votre zone de confort pour
acquérir sa discipline mais comment je
ne vous ai pas dit comment
pour sortie de zone de confort faut que
vous réalisiez de tâches que vous
n'aimez pas faire et que normalement
vous n'avez pas envie de faire mais je
vous donne un exemple chaque matin à
votre réveil 30 minutes à une heure
après votre réveil vous ne touchez pas à
cet appareil cet appareil c'est un
téléphone qui possède une lumière bleue
et cette lumière bleue c'est prouvé
scientifiquement qu'elle vous mène à
rester dessus beaucoup plus longtemps et
donc vous allez progrès signer et qu'est
ce que j'ai dis moi que qui dit
procrastination dire aux besoins de
tâches et qui dit deux dash 10 obstacles
discipline et obstacles succès est bien
à mesure que chaque jour quand vous vous
réveillez vous ne touchez pas ce
téléphone vous serez les maîtres même de
votre journée vous serez en contrôle
même de votre journée et vous allez
pouvoir dicter votre selle voir pour lui
dire quand le toucher et qu'on ne pas le
toucher alors que si vous commencez
votre journée en utilisant ce téléphone
vous allez être dans une dans une
optique donc négative et d'énergie
négatif puisqu'il est bourré donc
négative et d'énergie négative et donc
il va pour contrôler et il sera
l'obstacle même à la discipline
sortir de votre zone de confort
réaliser les tâches de 1000 par jour que
vous n'avez pas envie de faire se
réveiller tôt tout cela d'une manière ou
d'une autre même veine la discipline oui
mais je répète l'élément moteur
l'élément clé qui change toute la donne
c'est la manière avec laquelle vous
parler avec votre cerveau c'est la
manière avec laquelle vous manipuler
votre cerveau c'est la manière avec
laquelle vous essayez de le manipuler de
sorte à ce qu'ils soient dans une
optique qui est productive au long terme
et comment eh bien je vais vous faire
part d'une expérience de kaka que j'aime
beaucoup qui s'appelle saimone sari nec
et il m'a beaucoup inspiré
si je vous dis tous maintenant j'ai
besoin d'autre j'ai besoin de votre
temps de votre attention dans la salle
s'il vous plaît tous ici tous dans la
salle
ne pensez pas à un chien
1 vous voyez la première chose à
laquelle vous pensez c'est un chien mais
pourquoi puisque je vous ai dit de ne
pas penser à quelque chose et de ne pas
vous concentrer sur quelque chose et par
effet automatique vous allez vous
concentrer que sur ce quelque chose je
vous donne un autre exemple pour vous
expliquer après le sens des rires cela
si vous êtes en train de dévaler une
piste de ski et que devant vous il ya
des armes et aux longs au long chemin il
ya la ligne d'arrivée la finitude de
votre compétition on va dire on va
prendre on va faire on va on va
considérer que les armes c'est votre
obstacle dans votre projet de vie c'est
les obstacles dans votre projet de vie
et on va considérer que la ligne
d'arrivée c'est la finitude de votre
projet la finitude de ce que vous avez
envie d'accomplir qui vous mènera on
l'espère vers le succès et bien si vous
voulez dévalé la piste de ski et que
vous vous dites ne cogne pas s'éteindre
ne connais pas cet arbre ne connais pas
ce talent au final qu'est ce que vous
avez fait vous avez connu dame pourquoi
puisque vous ne regardez que là
vous ne vous concentrer que sur la rue
l'obstacle alors que si vous vous dites
je veux arriver à l'arrivée je veux
arriver à la une d'arriver et j'ai envie
d'arriver avant d'arriver et sur une
plus grande échelle je veux réussir dans
ma vie je veux réussir dans ma vie au
final vous allez réussir dans votre vie
parce que vous vous concentrez sur la
finitude de votre projet sur le but de
votre projet et non pas sur les
obstacles et bien le message derrière
cela c'est que vous devez manipuler
votre cerveau en parlons un peu plus
d'une manière positive et non pas
négative et sans vous concentrer sur les
obstacles qui seront devant vous puisque
c'est cela qui vont vous faire échouer
aux gros poissons tra sur les obstacles
ce qui vous empêche d'acquérir votre but
de vie
dit comme ça vous n'imaginez pas comment
cela pourrait vous aider plus tard mais
personnellement après un an et demi où
j'ai pratiqué le boot inn où les
situations inconfortables règne où les
hauts et les bas rhin je me sens
nettement différent à tous les points de
vue à tous les niveaux j'ai mûri à tous
les niveaux au niveau académique au
niveau sportif au niveau du mental de ma
manière de penser
j'ai gagné en maturité et j'ai gagné en
confiance en soi et c'est l'essentiel
pour une bonne réussite au cou durant
votre vie dans tout dans tout votre
parcours de vie c'est l'essentiel j'ai
pratiqué leur routine ou les situations
inconfortables règne je me suis obligé à
me mettre dans des situations
inconfortables pour pouvoir plus tard
dans le futur être apte à faire face aux
situations inconfortables qui seront
demandés pour moi pour que je puisse
réussir plus tard dans ma vie
professionnelle
et si je les fais c'est tellement simple
pour vous de le faire puisque j ai nommé
différencie de vous je suis un ado comme
vous je saurai week end je fais la fête
j'ai cet équilibre entre ma vie sociale
et ma vie de routine et c'est le plus
important cet équilibre on ne peut pas
être consistant 24 sur 7 mais on ne peut
pas aussi être dans l'amusant 24,7 faut
savoir faire la part des choses et
trouver cet équilibre qui va nous mener
vers la discipline peeters
14 janvier 2021 4 heures du matin le
déclic le jour qui a changé ma vie
jusqu'à présent le jour le jour où j'ai
décidé de prendre son futur en mains le
jour où je me suis créé une routine qui
m'a grandement aidé et je l'espère pour
plus tard dans mon parcours de vie et
une routine que si vous la créer
peut-elle vous aidera plus tard à vous
aussi on l'espère
tout est question de détermination
tout est question de manipulation avec
votre cerveau tout est question de
discipline merci à tous
[Applaudissements]